My favorite activity in Haiti
was simply walking the streets
and meeting the people.
Hey, this is Jean Luc, he
lives here in Port-au-Prince.
He says he watches me--
Every night.
Every single night,
that's so fantastic.
You say that you--
Hi, May-el.
You think you can do the
string dance, is that it?
Mm, mm, mm.
Yeah, and then what?
Hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey.
What's up, you do it all the time
on national TV.
Oh, yeah yeah, right.
(laughing) I forgot about that.
Hey, everybody, this is Shnayder,
you're from Port-au-Prince.
Yes.
And, I gotta say,
you've got some great style goin' on here.
I like the glasses, I like the belt.
You got it all goin' on.
Yeah, I'm a model so...
Do you think I could be a male model?
You should go to the
gym before. (laughing)
What the hell?
You should go to the gym before.
Excuse me, excuse me, is it okay if I try?
Could I try that?
Yes, try it.
Is it good, good?
Huh?
(yelling)
Oh, she's holding it.
I got it!
Viva Haiti!
(cheering)
President Trump
insulted Haiti, so I
thought it was only fair
to give Haitians a chance
to return the favor.
This is Philemon; Philemon, you live here
in Port-au-Prince, right?
Yes, I do.
Okay, now you know that
this the famous hat
that Trump wears, Make
America Great Again?
Yeah.
(laughing)
We thought we'd give you this hat.
Haiti Is Great Already, you like that?
All right, put that on.
Here we go.
Very good, very good, very good.
Sir.
Sir, sir.
If I could just--
Yes, yes, very good, oh my God!
I just missed my flight home.